per game he's now 20 points away from
10,000 klay Thompson grew up here said
his first 15 years of his life here
jadvyga
number-one hit for the Portland
Trailblazers interrupts them look at
that defense by Kevin Durant Durant who
is a candidate for Defensive Player of
the air he's number four in the NBA and
blocks about a candidate for MVP he's a
candidate for MVP is blank on the other
side of the break depending on what
Oklahoma City does I just think he has
been extraordinary he's averaging a near
triple-double it's just not erasing
right away curry has it worked away
Aminu the Terry Stotts ad has been their
best defensive player this year gets the
take away
one of the problems that the Warriors
have and their - real problems are the
best team in the land Marvin Gaye's
saying the greatest national anthem ever
then it was Shaq and then it was Kobe
and this is number five coming up
Georgia no I love the Lakers and I want
what's best for Luke that salaries got
bought that new TV you have is a Durant
hits and a foul a three-point
opportunity for KD is now missed two in
a row after hitting his first three
shots
push the ball Damien don't wait for
these guys
and a chance at 6-pin here in the first
point warriors turned the ball over they
have six turnovers two baskets and no
three Lillard with the left hand
and over the last three games he's got a
hundred and ten points is Durant gives
Golden State its first made 306 with
Larry Bird or the second place for that
fifteen years Michael Jordan's Bulls
with thirteen years after that
Durant hands it he's got 14 was a fight
every game every game they just fought
for a while they stopped it they started
playing together that was it Teddy
dealing with 16 points put that together
he lives in San Francisco now how long
of a bike ride is that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Iguodala finds Duran lets it fly in and
out rebounded by Green Durant gets to
the rim first 18 point but it's like you
play fantasy sports for money please
Durant drives again and yeah great spin
jegi come on that's guard skill what
they really need is the front porch to
come alive every game look at Kevin
Durant 22 is McCallum picks up another
foul Jim Barnett did for me when I was
13 years old
three points Lillard averaging 30 per
game in the month of February that
second best in the league time rattles
have hauled from three-point range ball
handling waiting for that clip to get
veterans fortunate accelerate basketball
ditched their job and he's got 29 points
on 16 shots and Golden State within
three they trailed at the end of the
first quarter by 13 real small lineup
and KD is not going to get back in there
and play the big man the best just get
here we'll take care of the rest
look at that back
[Music]
[Applause]
Miller here with
points great rotation lasers
Willard steps inside the arc and carries
it to 31 points rebored had a
triple-double in this building and then
against the Blazers play in left handed
I saw that on SportsCenter
has 33 points tastic the Warriors are in
that Joel a cub is flying his personal
plane up here to take the four all-star
straight to LA I hate flopping please
come to play ball don't come to abuse
the rules of human rebounds nice pump
fake
[Music]
[Applause]
four minutes until the all-star break
that have you heard Steve fair's
interview with Cassidy at the end of the
first quarter he said
[Music]
dean of the night and if the blazers do
win this game tonight these fans will
believe Durant's got 43 of 23 shot 42
[Applause]
and he's got 48 he lost it